ja fast vier monate tobt der blutige
krieg in der ukraine bereits und auch
heute wollen wir uns ansehen wo denn
genau gekämpft wird wie gekämpft wird
und welche taktiken die beiden seiten
ansehen wo gekämpft dass es in den
letzten tagen relativ eindeutig gekämpft
wird im donbass im osten der ukraine
dort sind es die drei regionen raki 4 im
norden lohans hier im osten und donetsk
ihr im süden wo die russische armee
versucht weiter vorzudringen wo sie
versucht ein kessel zu schlagen um die
region lohans und hans krieg wollen ist
es mal so hin dass dieses gebiet hier
was zu allergrößten teil von russland
besetzt wird mittlerweile nur fünf
prozent das ist dieser kleine portier
dieser kleine ort fünf prozent werden
von der ukraine gehalten und vor allem
ist es die wehr oder netto netz an
großstadt eine ehemalige großstadt
zumindest mit 100.000 einwohner
einwohnern mittlerweile sind etwa 95
prozent der bevölkerung dort gefürchtet
und wir schauen uns einmal an aufnahmen
direkt aus dem netz wie also dort die
straßenkämpfe vorangehen erste aufnahme
hier ein ukrainischer panzer der steht
also zwischen zwei häusern versucht
geschützt zu zu dort eine position zu
beziehen und schließt wir werden gleich
sehen auf ein hochhaus vor ihm in dem
russische soldaten ihre positionen
eingenommen haben hier also das hochhaus
wir sehen dass ein mehrgeschossiges
hochhaus und hier oben wahrscheinlich
scharfschützen die dort verschanzt waren
im etwa zehnten stockwerk die dort von
dem ukrainischen panzer angegriffen
werden aber nicht nur panzer sondern
auch mann gegen mann wird das ganze
gekämpft wir sehen hier
straßenschlachten in zivil netz das sind
ukrainischen einheiten man hört es
vielleicht auch die die mit ihren
maschinengewehren dort schießen und und
das ist ganz interessant einen
verletzten oder toten soldaten von der
straße bergen man sieht ihn jetzt nicht
ganz genau das ist ein russischer soldat
die uniform zeigt dass es ein russischer
soldat ist der unter umständen hier
versucht hat von von hinten die ukraine
anzugreifen dann aber dort
höchstwahrscheinlich getötet wurde und
jetzt von den ukrainern hier mit seinen
waffen sozusagen ja mehr an sie heran
geholt wird dass sie wie rodo netz wo
tatsächlich mann gegen mann kämpft wo
also ukrainische und russische soldaten
aber auch ukrainische söldner aus eben
dieser sogenannten volksrepublik lohans
die zwangsverpflichtet wurden von putin
dort gegen andere ukraine kämpfen
da ist der straßenkampf sehr sehr
schwierig und für beide seiten sehr
brutal darüber hinaus ist es aber so
dass russland weiter mit ab luther
überlegenheit hier mit schweren waffen
vorgehen wir sehen uns ganz kurz mal an
hier die stadt lugansk das ist die
größte stadt die ehemals größte stadt
schon seit 2014 unter russischer
kontrolle in der region und dort sehen
wir wie hier einen zug mit neuen panzern
ankommt dieser zug hier am bahnhof von
lohans gefilmt von einfach menschen die
dort gerade waren zu der zeit und wir
sehen hier massig neue t 80 bv hop
kampfpanzer aus ganz russland aus ganzen
beständen der ehemaligen roten armee
werden immer mehr panzer in die ukraine
geholt wir sehen teilweise moderne
panzer wie diese hier vom typ t 80
teilweise auch uralt panzer vom typ t 62
die schon seit den 80er jahren in den
depots stehen nicht mehr benutzt wurden
die aber jetzt reaktiviert werden von
russland wir sehen putin meint es
tatsächlich extrem ernst dieser krieg
ist überhaupt nicht vorbei für ihn
überhaupt nicht beendet sondern er will
hier weiter vorrücken was macht die
ukraine dagegen sie versucht zwei dinge
zum einen benutzt sie weiterhin diese
kombination aus drohnen auf der einen
seite und eben auch artillerie wir sehen
hier ein ukrainisch das
artilleriegeschütz ein sehr altes
artilleriegeschoss ebenfalls aus den
60er jahren was eben verzweifelt
versucht die russischen panzer
abzuschießen die sich in den besetzten
dörfern verschanzen auf der anderen
seite benutzt die ukraine aber auch
immer mehr minen also jamina die auf die
straßen gepackt wenn die auf die felder
gepackt werden weil man eben einfach
sonst nichts mehr hat um diese
russischen panzer aufzuhalten jetzt
gehen wir gleich ein mega explosionen
hier vorne das ist ein russischer
schützenpanzer vom typ bmw 1 der hier
explodiert ist und kurz darauf gehen die
ukraine noch mal hinsehen sich an was
davon überzeugen dass wir sehen da das v
1 eines der markenzeichen das eben ein
russisches armeefahrzeug war und der
geschützten der wieder abgetrennt wurde
dass also ein schützenpanzer da ist der
geschützturm der hier zerstört wurde
alles in allem ist russland weiter
krachend überlegen und drückt im donbass
gerade in luhansk weiter vor und die
ukraine wartet sehnsüchtig auf schwere
waffen aus dem westen und irgendwann
hoffentlich endlich auch deutsche
schwere waffen